i'm not good at languages how many times
have you said or
thought something like this if you've
ever tried to learn a language before
either by yourself or in school you've
probably had this thought quite a few
times
when we struggle to do something we
often try to let ourselves off the hook
by saying that we're not good enough or
not talented enough to do the thing we
want to do it gives us an easy way to
explain away our failures as well as an
excuse to stop trying
we have we've all done this at some time
or another but the truth is that
thinking about language learning in
terms of talent or simply being good
enough
can be quite dangerous why because what
you're doing
is placing a hard limit on what you can
achieve
in a world view based on talent
everything is binary you either have
talent
or you don't that's it no exceptions
if you believe in talent you run the
risk of selling yourself short
not just in languages but in everything
else too if you think you're not
talented enough
you will not even try and if you don't
try you will never achieve the things in
life that are both incredibly worthwhile
and incredibly challenging like learning
languages
you know what else is weird about talent
everyone talks about it but
no one can really tell you what it is to
most talent is just
being good at stuff but what sets apart
a talented language learner from
an untalented one okay if talent is real
and certain language learners have it
then there must be a way to find it
measure it and break it down into its
component parts
right well in the 50s and 60s
researchers on second language
acquisition tried to do just
that by delving into the cognitive
abilities of language learners
these researchers broke down the
cognitive ability of the average
language learner
into the following four categories one
phonemic coding which is the capacity
of distinguishing phonemes by using a
phonetic script two grammatical
sensitivity that is the capacity of
identifying the grammatical functions of
words in a sentence
three inductive learning ability the
capacity to generalize
patterns from one sentence to another
and four rote
learning ability that is the capacity to
retain
lists of words paired with translations
based on these categories researchers
designed a test called the modern
language aptitude test or mlat for short
unfortunately this test is not available
to individual language learners like you
and i
that being said if you're part of an
agency or other organization that is
interested in ordering the exam
i've put more information in the
description box anyway
the mlat is aimed at determining how
quickly and
effectively language learners can
perform certain language related tasks
given optimal instructions conditions
and motivation
as it turns out test takers displayed a
variety of skill sets
some were great at remembering words but
not good with phonetic scripts
others had figured out grammar functions
in a sentence but not
at generalizing patterns makes sense
right
you may have noticed the same thing with
your own language skills
maybe for example you're great at
remembering words but you have trouble
figuring out grammar patterns or
you're good at learning new scripts but
you're terrible at distinguishing
similar sounds
other researchers used the mlat to
further explore
the concept of language aptitude and
found out that students who found
success in language learner
did so through following their natural
inclinations and
interests in other words they were
successful languages because they
learned languages in a way that suited
them
personally in other words even if you're
not particularly strong in all the
aspects of your language aptitude
if your learning style reflects your
cognitive strengths
you can still find success now in my
experience as a polyglot
people have told me countless times that
i have an innate talent for language
one that i was born with some have even
theorized that my brain is somehow more
suited to language learning than that of
an average person
this could be true but i truly doubt it
i honestly think that my success in
acquiring multiple languages does not
simply boil down to my inner cognitive
abilities
in fact my cognitive abilities are just
one of the six
main factors that make up success in
language learners
which we'll explore shortly i believe
this because i know the cognitive
abilities are not fixed
they can change over time and even
dramatically back in the day
it was generally taken for granted that
the brain structure does not change
in the course of one's life now however
scientists know that the brain
can change according to how it's used a
concept called
neuroplasticity so even if you do not
have the brain for
language learning right here and right
now with practice and dedication
you could certainly develop it you just
need to start using your brain in a way
that's conducive
to language learning and do that as much
as you can
so with a good excellent i'd say a bit
of news that anyone can become good at
language learning
even without a natural born talent there
are other additional factors that can
influence language ability
and the best part is that these factors
are not at all
related to the quality of your brain or
the quality of your genes
including what we already discussed
there are six factors that
make a great language learner let's look
at them together
one cognitive ability two motivation
three mindset four meta learning
five time on task and last but not least
life circumstances your cognitive
abilities comprise everything we've been
talking about so far
if you're already good at learning
learning is something that you want to
do more often
when i was learning english or french
and i got complimented for my accent or
for my fluency
i got even more excited to achieve more
with my skills and this is normal
as people we tend to do things we find
relatively easy
and for which we get social recognition
so in my language learning path
my cognitive abilities have surely
played a role but again
i don't think that they are the main
reason why i have learned so many
languages so successfully the second
factor is
motivation without motivation you're not
going to achieve
anything no matter how talented you are
the world in fact is
full of talented people who haven't
accomplished much with their skills
in this way your talent does not define
your success
your motivation does language learning
is a long journey and the people who
reach the end of it are those
who know exactly why they strive to keep
learning day in
and day out personally i have discovered
that i learn languages to fluency
because i do not treat them like
any of the other skills i have instead i
treat them as a fundamental part of my
life
and my development as a person as an
individual once i start learning a
language there is no turning back
motivation is the fuel that makes
language learning happen
without it you'll go nowhere the third
factor is your emotional intelligence i
learned about this concept from the book
emotional intelligence written by daniel
goloman
in the book goleman distinguishes
rational intelligence the kind of
intelligence that can be measured by an
iq test
where they mainly test your logical and
mathematical skills from
emotional intelligence which is
something that can't be measured by a
simple test
this kind of intelligence has to do with
the capacity to understand yourself to
control yourself and your emotions
and to be able to understand others all
of these factors
coincidentally play a huge role in
learning a foreign language which is why
i believe emotional intelligence
is a core factor in language learning
success emotional intelligence
is also connected with your mindset the
good news is that you can work on your
mindset
and your emotional intelligence like
your cognitive abilities they are not
fixed i myself have worked a lot over
the years on both my emotional
intelligence and my mindset
my mindset has completely changed when
it comes to language learning
and life in general and this is due to
experiences by attitude people i met on
the path
and many other things all great language
learners develop
a positive mindset they don't speak
languages to get praise
but rather they speak to communicate
when someone corrects them they don't
take it as an insult but as constructive
feedback
when you develop a positive mindset
every moment of the language learning
journey is a treasure
be they moments of success or moments of
failure
the fourth factor is time on task
malcolm gladwell
i read most of his books and the sky is
just phenomenal introduced the popular
concept
of the 10 000 hours role the main idea
of this rule is that in order to get
good at a skill
you have to spend thousands and
thousands of hours learning and honing
it
if you think about the average amount of
time a native speaker has put into
learning their own language you will
realize that as a learner you have a
long
road ahead of you your capacity to
understand speak
read and even write a foreign language
depends heavily on how much time you
invest in each
of these activities but time is not the
only factor at hand here
in fact there are a lot of learners who
spend a lot of time learning languages
but do not get much value from it
honestly i don't think that the actual
act of learning a language is hard per
se
what is hard is putting in the time
discipline and
effort to actually get learning done you
need to spend a lot of time
know how to spend that time in a smart
way to stretch your boundaries
and develop the discipline you need to
make it happen again and again
over the long term the fifth factor is
your meta learning awareness
successful language learners spend an
awful amount of
time learning foreign languages but on
top of that
they know how to use their time they
know how to use their energy
and cognitive abilities efficiently they
have gone through a long and difficult
trial and error process
learning to discard what does not work
and refine and work on what does
great language learners are conscious of
their own
learning process and work to control and
guide its development
the combination of quantity and quality
of time makes them
incredible language learning machines
they continually ask themselves
what am i good at in language learning
that's the way i'm learning play to my
strengths
and they use the answers to those
questions to improve their strategies
and make progress
i've asked myself these questions and
more time and time again
over the course of the last 30 years and
i'm proud to say i've started to think
out of the box
that has given me the opportunity to
learn as much as i have
the sixth and last factor is your life
circumstances
how you live counts a lot the people you
decide to spend time with
the experiences you have the countries
you visit
what you do in your free time in my life
i've chosen to live and breathe
languages all day long
and that has led me to live a life that
currently allows me to use at least
five to eight languages every day and
some for hours on end
without cultivating the circumstances
which allow me to use and communicate in
one or more languages on a highly
frequent basis
it will be exceedingly difficult for me
and you to reach a high level of
language learning success
a final key observation can you see how
all these six factors are connected
and how profoundly they can influence
each other honestly they're so entangled
that it's impossible to say that one is
more important than any of the others
your cognitive abilities can give you
motivation your mindset maintains that
motivation
life circumstances meaning a potential
new romantic partner or making friends
with someone who speaks your target
language
can make a whole lot of difference if
you have a language
partner you can start using language
more and more without even having to
dedicate deliberate time to it
here i'd like to quote accomplish
linguist you did corbyn's own words
special talent or knack for languages is
really a conglomerate of abilities that
interact dynamically with the situation
in which
learning takes place if by any chance
you're wondering if you will
ever reach the heights of the most
famous polyglots out there
if you're wondering if you're currently
as talented as them
here's my piece of advice for you
language learning is a personal journey
every language learner walks a different
and unique path
though comparing journeys can sometimes
be motivating
it can often be hurtful and demotivating
here's how to make it work for you
every single time you see apollo strut
their stuff and wow you with their
skills
use that to give yourself some extra
energy and motivation
transform that inspiration to the
motivation you need to take action
work on yourself work on your goals work
on your skills
your success in the end is not defined
by talent it's defined by your thoughts
the people you meet
how you act and react to failures and
successes i
truly believe that you can learn any
language you set your mind to
that you can do it faster and better
than you think by working on the six
factors i've described in this video
though your genes may play a small part
in your development as a language
learner
all of the other factors are in your
hands you're ultimately responsible for
your
own language learning success so go for
it as they say
shoot for the moon even if you miss
you'll land them on the stars
on a final note i wanted to personally
thank dr gareth popkins for his
contribution to his discussion both in
the form of a great article he wrote on
the topic
and a great talk he gave at the polygam
gathering in 2018 you can find the links
in the description box and as always
thanks for watching
you